se voir à travers les yeux de quelqu'un
d'autre permet aussi de se rendre compte
que finalement mais on n'est pas si
moche que ça
[Musique]
tu veux te tutoyer ça va maintenant s'il
ya un moment donné ça va pas pour toi
que tu me dis enfin je ne le sens pas il
n'y a pas de souci on arrête on va
ailleurs ok tu peux te mettre ici alors
oui
ça va on se détend
ok
[Musique]
tu dois regarder là tout simplement
août et même pas obligé de regarder tu
peux regarder ailleurs ça y'a pas de
soucis aussi en fait c'était à mon école
donc
on a commencé à m'insulter
et donc du coup bas j'étais le dire à
monsieur
et monsieur punis
celui qui m'a insulté
mais après il a recommencé ça a duré
environ trois mois à peu près et ça
continue encore un peu maintenant on
voit qu'il n'hésiterait pas on va dire
taper
personnellement moi ça me fait peur
détente et doit
hockey
ça va
mon idée c'était de pouvoir montrer
cette personne m ce que tu vois toi
n'est pas correct parce que moi je te
vois autrement et je te vois tels que tu
es c'est à dire quelqu'un qui est bien
qui est beau et je veux essayer que
quand il voit la photo ils disent ah
ouais
je me vautre mans se voir à travers les
yeux de quelqu'un d'autre permet aussi
de se rendre compte que finalement mais
on n'est pas si moche que ça tu vas en
faire une avec ta maman
c'est un sujet qui me touche beaucoup
parce que j'en ai été victime aussi je
sais que c'est pas évident la vie
scolaire
les critiques sont énormes c'est pas
évident se faire des amis c'est une
souffrance qui est interne qui est
constante si j'avais pu avoir quelqu'un
qui m'avait proposé mais si tu veux je
fais des photos quoi que ce soit je
pense que je l'aurais fait
en tant que maman on se sent vraiment
impuissant il a totalement perdu
confiance
il se sent parfois
moche mais faut dire à l'école on lui
dit tous les jours et il a fini par le
croire en face à l'entendre il a fini
par le croire donc je pense que cette
séance photo lui a permis un peu de
de se sentir important
oui
je
on
étant donné que j'étais un très grand
longs cheveux danseurs c'était un peu
mal vu à l'école j'ai eu énormément
d'insultés énormément d'attac surtout
morale
[Musique]
en
le rapport qu'on aura avec sa propre
image est très important on a besoin de
pouvoir s'accepter il faut absolument
avoir confiance en soi si on n'a pas
confiance en soi forcément toutes les
attaques qu'on va nous sortir vont
automatiquement nous atteindre et le
principe est justement de pouvoir
être attaquée sans être touché
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]